je demande jean michel mr contre
catherine laborde d'accord this is it ok
mais là ici ici attention alors c'est le
paulina elle est comme l'art de finale
attention on y va on démarre par jean
michel maire mais quel mytho 58 58
kilomètres raconte jean michel lair 100
km/heure en maille s'il vous plaît bien
[Applaudissements]
suit pas et ça me semble pas qu'on va
faire mais pas complètement dans la zone
de confort aux allées à bout avec
catherine laborde chez vous on peut
aller très vite at-on regarder ça
faudrait que tu sois là mon chéri tout
nous dit diane parce que sinon on va pas
s'en sortir donc tout à fait quarante
années c'est sûr merci j'ai un imac et
qualifie la puissance mondiale
en fait oui mais non mr départ merci
madame tomber merci à l'affût 62 allez-y
62 ans géraldine maillet tarot club
c'est pas mal du tout géré à dilma des
calices et soixante c'est le record
c'est le sport c'est le record il y en a
dans le bras maire de port merci
attention les chiffres et le film et
c'est la demi-finale à 3 à 3 le meilleur
me rencontrera et sarah je vais tout
faire pour que tu gagnes maafiri on y va
ne pas tuer de l'ormeau c'est parti
l'intervention c'est parti
62 62 très beau score de mathieu de la
terrible et très beau score de mathieu
d'orgue la finale se joue en deux points
égalité si géraldine fait plus salée
directe self et moi on fera pour vous
départ peut être un nom inattendu 52
s'est perdue produire a dit merci
[Rires]
voilà tandis qu'un 75 tu sais bouillon
de leurs mots 61 10 et en plus il avait
mordu c
ouais bah s'échelonnaient de béziers le
monde et les racines du mal attention
c'est parti je vais faire comme sa belle
mort de ces mordus c'est mort
ces mordus et menthe est ce qu'on peut
avoir un arbitrage armé méritait la
peine soit après paris morts ouais je
lui martin sur la gueule
ah non non non il doit pas mordre mais
pas lors du 64 c'est pas mordu à points
0,37 mais ça a merdé
c'est possible alors matin et la neige
costumes pertinents
cette annonce est optimisé entre levin
mise bien entre les lignes c'est gagné
merci
sarah tuera pas avec tout cas thomas
beauté
à son bord
surtout c'était magnifique